i am in the elements that is it's  drizzling right now and even our  producers said you look cold it's very  cold the temperature dropped drastically  take a look at the traffic as it's  moving at a good pace we're near blue  diamond and decatur about 10 minutes  from our previous location the wind  seems to be a little less intense here  but like i said it's colder near  in this area but near i-15 and cactus  no rain just drizzle that's where we  were before the rain that we are going  to see later on has made its way down  from the north as people are getting  home from work it's best to just stay  indoors tonight the wind will continue  to pick up throughout the evening and  the rain will make the roadways slick so  keep it here on 8 news now as we will  keep you posted on weather conditions